you have to sacrifice them
to get some we want a new car we want a
house we want an apartment
they want everything but they don't
really want to put in the work and I got
to where I got to by putting in the work
I'm sacrificing a lot of things and I
knew that eventually that
my hard work and dedication will pay off
and I will be at the Pinnacle and no one
would stop me from getting no one would
stop me from getting to where I was
trying to get to no one could stop me
I've never really viewed myself as
particularly talented where I excel is
ridiculous
sickening work ethic you know while the
other guy's sleeping I'm working while
other guys eating I'm working greatness
is not this
wonderful esoteric elusive
god-like feature that only the special
Among Us will ever taste you know it's
something that truly exists in all of us
it's very simple
this is what I believe
and I'm willing to die for it
period
it's that simple the separation of
talent and skill is one of the the the
the greatest misunderstood concepts for
people who are trying to excel who have
dreams that want to do things talent you
have naturally skill is only developed
by hours and hours and hours of beating
on your craft I realized that when you
to to have the level of success that I
want to have is difficult to spread it
out and do multiple things it takes such
a desperate obsessive Focus you really
gotta focus with all of your fiber and
all of your heart and all your
creativity let me explain something to
you
when you go out and try to do anything
outside the norm and I'm talking
anything outside the norm you are going
to be faced with negativity you're going
to have people misunderstand you and
because they misunderstand you and
because you are doing something that
they don't do whether they agree with
what you do or not is irrelevant they're
just not familiar with it okay what do
people do when they don't understand
things they usually attack them they
usually put negativity towards it they
usually project their own insecurities
and their own reservations about what it
is they are incapable of doing and they
put them on you and so when you start
out in business or you start out on a
weight loss Journey or you start out to
be a better person you are going to face
negativity and I don't give what any of
these frou-frou fluffy Guru Partners out
there tell you okay everybody likes to
Pretend This is an ideal place they like
to think that everything's really going
to be nice and it's going to be easy and
it's going to be this and I just had a
really hard time telling you guys
because it's not true if you can become
someone that can transfer negativity
into productive action you are literally
Unstoppable by outside circumstances and
outside elements
the only person that can stop you when
you're able to do this is you and the
way you stop you is you can burn
yourself down right you can get too
negative you can get too hot you can get
too frustrated so it's something that
you need to learn how to Pivot on but
also control in a productive way
everybody has dreams and and and as much
as you you want to be able to listen a
little bit because somebody's gonna give
you a gem but you nobody knows but you
you can't get advice on what you should
do with your life right nobody knows
what you are like even even sometimes
you don't really even know what you what
you are you got to take your shot and
it's like as much as you want people to
agree and you want the people around you
to be supporting your dreams and all
it's not going to be like that all the
time you got to do it alone and people
will help you and when you when you get
the ball rolling people will jump on but
if you don't believe nobody else is
going to believe people come along
because your belief is so insane
following your dreams
is a lonely solitary scary dangerous
Pursuit you can't wait for somebody to
think you can do it
and it's like they they because they
don't think you can do nothing they
can't do exactly you know what I mean
it's like it it's a lonely scary
dangerous Pursuit and you got to be
willing to risk everything to become
that seed of what you believe it's in
there you gotta be Fearless you got to
be relentless life and the way it works
and no matter what you want to do when I
say this you can get mad about it you
can argue with it you can say it's not
true it doesn't matter it's no different
than gravity you go take a step off the
building you could say gravity's all you
want but you're gonna crack skull on the
ground
and if you think that life doesn't work
in a very simple equation which is
what you put in you will get out
you are gonna [__] lose
you know why the results are never there
because you can think about it you can
wish for it you can hope for it you can
think all about it all as long as you
want but unless you get out every single
[__] day and put in the work inch by
inch
you will never get there I'm not the
smartest guy in the [__] Earth not
even close but I figured out one thing
that when you follow the plan as it's
supposed to and you work to build the
skills that it takes to actually adhere
to the plan meaning your disciplined
your fortitude your ability to endure
okay your grit your determination
your self-esteem your self-worth your
confidence that you can achieve what it
is you want to achieve these are all
[__] skill sets when you learn to
develop these skills even if you don't
have the talent I don't have any Talent
you guys all think I have talent because
I've been doing for a long time I do not
have any Talent
I grew up just like you
but what I learned was when I developed
these skills and when I invest in these
skills and I continuously sharpen these
skills the ones I'm talking about
I can achieve great things and if I
could achieve great things and I'm a
regular dude who grew up on a [__]
Gravel Road who is a fat little kid that
everybody made fun of
I'm pretty sure you can too
that which you do not hate you will
eventually tolerate and I think that
identifies most people's lives in other
words they
average becomes sort of like this slow
asphyxiation it's almost like an
anesthetic and that over time we become
kind of immune and dulled to the average
that we're becoming you're going to get
out of your life what you'll accept
that's really difficult for people I
think to understand is look what you
think you're worth and what you're going
to tolerate is absolutely what you're
going to bring into your life and what
the outward part of your life is going
to look like and so I live by that like
I let myself sort of feel the pain and
the difficulty of of being not where I
want to be and whatever that area is
whether it's my spirituality my
relationships my money I let myself feel
that pain because as you know there's
two motivators right there's the gaining
of pleasure right wanting to go get
something chasing the dream but then
there's the avoidance of pain and for a
lot of Champions that's a pretty big
driving force for them and so at least
for me I I leverage both of those things
on me to get myself to take action so
that's what that means to me